foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear and we're doing another giallo
movie this week uh this is actually in
1971 movie and this kind of turns up on
a lot of lists that I've seen around the
internet as one of the best most classic
yellow movies but on the other hand I
feel like it doesn't really get as much
attention or love as some of the other
like better known more beloved uh you
know movies that are in the sub-genre
and I have to say that that is really a
goddamn shame because this is actually a
brilliant uh giallo film and even though
like the first time I saw it was you
know probably [ __ ] five or ten years
ago it was a long time ago and I loved
it back then but I mean I enjoyed it
even more the second time around when I
re-watched it uh for this video I mean
it's not only like a really intriguing
mystery that really kind of sucks you in
and the way that it's structured you
know it's kind of like this really
really tense like flashback uh kind of
thing going on but it's also just
visually beautiful it's very very
skillfully written there's a lot of kind
of like cool like symbolism and stuff
and it has an amazing amazing score by
ennio morricone now the movie has
several different titles just like a lot
of these Italian uh movies tend to do so
it's also known as malastrana which is
actually uh named after a district in
Prague which is where the story takes
place
or I think it was originally supposed to
be titled short night of the butterfly
that actually makes more sense in
regards to the plot because there are a
whole bunch of symbolic references in
the film to a particular kind of
flightless butterfly but the film was
eventually released under the title
short night of glass dolls due to
another movie with butterfly in the
title being released at right around the
same time and they didn't really want
the confusion now I'm guessing that the
glass dolls of the title maybe is kind
of like referring to the fragility or
Youth of the victims that like turn up
in the movie but it's I admittedly it's
a pretty tenuous connection then again
Glo titles don't usually make all that
much sense so I'm not really complaining
that much about it it is actually kind
of a cool like evocative title even
though it doesn't really have anything
to do with the story uh regardless
that's neither here nor there this was
actually the director real debut of Aldo
lado who would actually go on to direct
another classic giallo uh who saw her
die from 1972 which I think I've covered
on this uh series at some point or
another so short night of glass dolls
has an unusual uh specifically for a
giallo uh but also pretty creative
conceit or setup uh one that's kind of
similar I guess to maybe Sunset
Boulevard or there was also an old
episode of Alfred Hitchcock Presents I
think from the first season from 1955
which is called breakdown this kind of
has the same setup as that so our main
character uh who's an American
journalist named Gregory Moore who's
actually played by a french actor Jean
Sorel he was very prolific and I
recognized him immediately from the
excellent 1967 movie beldu Jour with
Catherine denove which is really good if
you haven't seen it uh so Gregory our
main character is found apparently dead
in a public park at the beginning of the
movie however a voiceover lets the
audience know that he's still very much
alive and is presumably suffering from
some type of cataleptic situation uh but
he's very frustratingly unable to tell
anyone else like what's going on uh you
know he is it's basically a locked in
syndrome he's just like laying there
seeming like a dead body and he can't
like tell anybody about this terrifying
predicament that he's in so the entire
mystery of how he ended up like this is
detailed in flashback as Gregory is
essentially laying in the morgue waiting
for you know to get autopsy do you know
what I mean so he's just kind of like I
have to remember how I got in this
situation because he's kind of like
disoriented so he's trying to like
remember it's kind of cool because
they'll have like he'll be like I have
to remember I have to remember and then
like he'll have like these weird flashes
of like these kind of seemingly random
like nightmares kind of images but then
like as his memories become more
coherent like it sort of like you know
gets into like a regular story so the
film actually flips back and forth
between the doctor's kind of fruitless
attempts to revive him it so happens
that Gregory has a friend that's a
doctor like who went to college with him
and uh that friend he spends longer than
he usually would like trying to
resurrect Gregory because he can't
understand like why the body temperature
of this supposed corpse is you know
still that of a living person
um so it flips back and forth between
the doctors trying to wake him back up
and Gregory's memories of getting
involved in this big conspiratorial
[ __ ] that led him to this whole
sad State of Affairs it's actually like
a really really good plot device because
not only are you kind of sucked into the
whole main mystery as it's unfolding but
you're also kind of held in really nail
biting suspense over the course of the
movie oh over whether Gregory is going
to be like woken up out of his
death-like trance or whatever before the
autopsy knife you know ends his life for
real so it's a really really good like
very tension building uh narrative
device so as I said Gregory kind of
slowly his through his memories he
slowly starts to reconstruct the story
for the benefit of the audience now as I
mentioned he's a journalist and he's
been on assignment covering political
unrest in Prague particularly the Soviet
Crackdown that occurred in the wake of
the Prague spring in 1968. now while
there he's also met and fallen in love
with a young beautiful Czech woman uh
named Mira now Mira is played by Barbara
Bach who was also in another jail movie
black belly of the tarantula which I
think I've covered on here uh she was
also a Bond girl she was in the spy who
loved me and uh incidentally is also
married to Ringo Starr so you know
there's that she's been in a bunch of
stuff he falls in love with her and is
planning to kind of pull some strings
with use his connections to smuggle her
out of the country and back to London
with him like at the end of his
assignment now as I said she seems to
like love him back just as much and
she's very very hopeful uh you know
seemingly that these plans will work out
and be successful because she wants to
get the [ __ ] out of here but then some
weird [ __ ] happens late one night after
a party they go to this party that's got
a kind of fancy cocktail party there's
all these like high muckety mucks or
whatever in there uh she's you know he
kind of introduces her around and all
these creepy old dudes are kind of like
vulturing around it's like trying to
strike up conversations being creepy you
know like they do
um so they go to that party and it's
whatever and then they go home and then
they go to sleep and then Gregory gets a
call in the middle of the night which
turns out to be a story tip like from
one of his uh informers or whatever so
he goes out there to check it out
and it turns out to be nothing so he's
like okay well that was a [ __ ] waste
of time um but then when he gets back to
his apartment uh Mira is missing
now the weirdest thing about her
disappearance is that she didn't take
anything with her she didn't take her
handbag with all her passport money and
also she apparently didn't take any of
her clothes like even the dress that she
wore to the party is still in the
apartment kind of flung over the back of
the chair like she just took it off and
then supposedly just went parading out
into the night Stark naked because he's
like look I'm sure that all of her
clothes are here all of her shoes are
here all of her [ __ ] is here it's like
she wouldn't have just like wandered out
somebody took her out now as is normal
for giallo movies the police are
dismissive and really not only useless
but actively hostile like toward
Gregory's efforts to track down his
missing girlfriend you get the
impression pretty early on that the cops
are maybe part of this larger conspiracy
and at every turn they either kind of
like discourage Gregory or try to
threaten him like for pursuing his own
investigation for questioning his own
Witnesses stuff like that either by
openly kind of accusing him of killing
her or having something to do with her
death or trying to convince him that hey
you know girls disappear from here all
the time she probably just took off on
her own and spreading stories around
that she had told other people that she
was planning to leave so of course
Gregory isn't buying that though it's
like she wouldn't do that
um and with the help of two of his
journalist colleagues uh this kind of
chummy guy named Jacques who's played by
Mario a dorf I guess he's like a German
actor and uh the scaldingly jealous and
also kind of lovesick Jessica who's
played by uh the ingmar Bergman regular
Ingrid Thulin she's actually in love
with Gregory and she just does not like
she's like why are you going around
looking for that little [ __ ] blah blah
blah and he's like [ __ ] you don't even
know her so it's like this whole like
conflict situation which I actually
really liked
so while the three of them are like you
know playing Scooby-Doo or whatever
Gregory starts to uncover
a series of similar disappearances of
young women in Prague which kind of
seems like it was covered up a little
bit and there it you know like I said
the Sim the similarities between like
all of these women kind of disappeared
from their own Apartments their own
houses and they uh again like didn't
take anything with them like they just
did they didn't have their clothes and
things or any of their belongings and uh
so he's like okay well obviously there's
some connection there but he kind of you
know he's kind of like asking around but
nobody really wants to talk to him
because they're just all like you can
tell that they're just kind of like oh
[ __ ] I can't tell you anything because
I'll get in trouble
um now oddly one thing that he does find
out is all of the girls that disappeared
um are kind of Were Somehow involved
with chamber music like either as
musicians or as like devotees like
people that would come there and like
see the chamber music performances or
whatever so it soon comes to light that
the epicenter of the mystery
sort of resides in this mysterious
chamber music venue known only as Club
99.
and as Gregory kind of probes deeper
into what its true purpose is because
it's kind of like it's seemingly on the
surface like somewhere where all these
high like again like the high marketing
mugs come and like watch chamber music
performances but obviously there's
probably something else going on you
know with it it's kind of like a front
so while he kind of probes deeper into
that he kind of starts encountering like
the whole Bevy of like shady ass
characters who again like either
Stonewall him completely threatened to
kill him or or you know alternately end
up dead like shortly before or after
giving him information so obviously
there's some big conspiracy having to do
with this music venue and all of these
young girls that went missing and it was
all like a big cover-up now in a similar
vein to the Sergio Martino classic all
the colors of the dark uh the Sinister
forces which are operating behind Club
99 appear to be a cult or satanic in
nature uh so you got that going on and
also short night of glass dolls on top
of that like weaves in a pretty overt uh
political statement about the elderly
ruling class like society's top echelons
being essentially these sort of perverse
and almost like vampiric people or
creatures uh who drain the life like
both literally and figuratively from the
unfortunate young people beneath them
now it's here that I think it's a shame
that they had to change the title
because the original butterfly metaphor
was really relevant because there's like
a plot point in the film that centers
around a species of butterfly that has
these beautiful gorgeous like colorful
wings but they're useless like they
can't fly they just kind of like crawl
around in the in the bushes and stuff
like that because you know they can't
use them to fly so basically he's making
an analogy between the butterflies that
can't fly that are beautiful and
everything uh but the obvious symbolism
being that that the beautiful young
people of the Czech Republic are being
held down and exploited by this
oppressive regime that maintains a
Stranglehold over the nation like all
these vampiric like old people at the
top they're just kind of like sucking up
all the stuff from the bottom now
incidentally in the resolution of the
mystery of this film I would actually
Hazard a guess that this was a this
movie was a precursor or maybe an
inspiration for Stanley Kubrick's Eyes
Wide Shut like thematically it's kind of
similar where there's this creepy like
almost like a cult cabal of Elites that
are kind of like controlling all of this
stuff so it's kind of like a similar
thing going on here now this movie like
I said it looks gorgeous I mean the
Prague backdrop of the film is just a
real highlight it's kind of like really
beautiful and elegant but also kind of
like really dispiriting and oppressive
at the same time which kind of handily
ties in with the whole subtext of the
movie
um there's also like all these other
really like I said really gorgeous
imagery of these kind of like glass
Crystal like crystal chandeliers and
butterflies and those beautiful like
Baroque interiors that I love so much
um I also really liked some of the
seemingly random like unsettling little
scenes and details in here like for
example the best one there's like a guy
who's maybe like one of the elite guys
and he's experimenting on Plants uh
particularly tomatoes and trying to
determine if they can feel pain like
he's got them like you know hooked up to
the little meter thing
um and I liked this because this little
sequence even though you're watching it
you're like why the [ __ ] is that in the
movie it's because it's mirroring
Gregory's catalyptic situation like you
know campaign can plants feel pain like
you can see it on the on the meter thing
but it's like you can't hear them and
it's like that was the same thing that
was going on with him like he was in a
catalyptic state and he's laying there
in the morgue like screaming internally
like hey like don't kill me I'm still
alive blah blah blah but nobody could
hear him
um and also I want to say too that it
also served
kind of double uh Duty because it also
kind of ingeniously like foreshadowed
the ending uh which I won't spoil now I
will say that I could have done without
the scene of the hippie guy singing that
cringe-worthy and seemingly endless song
about butterflies but I mean you can't
have everything it's only it's probably
really only like a minute or two but it
seemed like [ __ ] Eternal like that
song because it was so lit just like
made me so embarrassed for the person
but you know yeah so I could have done
without that
um but you can't have everything you
know and really that's kind of the only
sour note in the whole film which is
otherwise a really uh impeccably
realized very suspenseful mystery that
has a really a really good like shocking
and kind of cruel resolution uh that I
totally didn't really see coming
so if you're into gialo movies and
somehow haven't had a look at this one I
actually recommend it really really
highly it's one that seems to get
overlooked like pretty often and for
whatever reason but it absolutely needs
more love because it's really really
good and I really enjoyed it um much
more the second time like I said you
know it's kind of I don't want to say
like it's slowly paced but it's paced
about the same as like some other Jello
movies if you find Jello movies slow in
general you'll probably find this slow
as well but honestly the mystery of this
is just so intriguing and like I said
the whole Race Against Time where he's
like holy [ __ ] I'm gonna get autopsied
and I'm still alive in here that's like
really [ __ ] up so you're kind of
hoping that everything will be resolved
like before he you know gets cut up or
whatever so I feel like the suspense of
that is really really good but yeah this
is a great great giallo film so if you
haven't seen it and you're into jail
movies then definitely check it out
because it's one of the best ones and
like I said I feel like it doesn't get
as much attention tension and some of
the other ones so that'll do it for this
flickers of fear hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will see you guys again on the
next one bye